[Música]
en américa latina se agudiza la crisis
alimentaria que amenaza al llamado
granero del mundo la guerra en ucrania
por una vez más en evidencia las
deficiencias de la producción de
alimentos en nuestra región la región
américa latina y el caribe juega
entonces un papel fundamental en la
seguridad alimentaria global según la
firma la oficina regional de la fao pese
a que la producción en américa latina'
alcanzaría para alimentar a toda su
población el programa mundial de
alimentos prevé que la región atravesará
una de las crisis más agudas en su
historia en materia de inseguridad
alimentaria como consecuencia de esta
guerra en ucrania también actualmente
unos 9.3 millones de latinoamericanos
sufren inseguridad alimentaria el
programa mundial elemento se calcula que
a raíz de esta guerra se podrían ver
afectados unos 13.3 millones de personas
adicionalmente también hay cambio
climático y otros factores que vamos
entonces a analizar en nuestra segunda
mitad del día ella es carolina trivelli
asesora en análisis estratégicos de
innovación de la fao para américa latina
y el caribe gracias carolina por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 buena mañana de martes le
pregunta entonces las actuación real la
situación de seguridad alimentaria en
nuestra región
buenos días raúl muchas gracias por la
oportunidad
efectivamente estamos enfrentando una
situación de altísima preocupación en el
mundo pero en américa latina y el caribe
en particular esta no es una situación
que ha sucedido de la noche a la mañana
esto es una situación que ya viene de
unas tendencias preocupantes sólo para
ilustrarlo entre el 2014 y el 2020 la
inseguridad alimentaria moderada o grave
aumento 16 puntos porcentuales en
américa latina y el caribe
pasando de 30% a
41% perdon pasando a 41% muy por encima
del promedio global que es 30% esto se
explica por la reducción en el ritmo de
mejora económica y de reducción de
pobreza en la región y por fenómenos
climáticos que han estado afectando a la
región pero esto se ha visto acelerado y
agravado por la crisis derivada de la
pandemia derivada de lakovic 19
y por la subsecuente crisis económica
que ha afectado a los países de la
región sobre ello más los problemas
climáticos como tú decías más la guerra
en ucrania la situación es de altísima
preocupación y se espera una situación
aún más grave para este año esta
situación aún más grave que se espera
para este año pues lamentable realmente
es como se pudiera grabar digamos el
factor determinante sería el cambio
climático sería la situación económica
de nuestra región de américa latina y el
caribe cuál sería ese factor
determinante que agravaría todo el
panorama
desgraciadamente la región no tenemos un
factor determinante tenemos la
confluencia de un conjunto de factores
un proceso de recuperación económica más
lento del esperado un que se traduce en
un proceso de reducción de pobreza y de
menos capacidad en los hogares en
particular en los más pobres para
adquirir alimentos suficientes para
alimentarse de manera independiente
con
situaciones de gobiernos que han quedado
muy golpeados después de la pandemia por
lo tanto con limitado espacio fiscal
para seguir generando
procesos de ayuda a las familias más
pobres más cambio climático más
restricciones al comercio que afectan la
por ejemplo disponibilidad de
fertilizantes suficientes en la región o
acceso a fertilizantes con muy alto
costo que pueden traducirse en
reducciones de la producción como tú
decías américa latina produce más
alimentos de los que consume pero
también américa latina es una de las
regiones más desiguales del planeta por
lo tanto la distribuir la accesibilidad
a esos alimentos no es igual para todos
los latinoamericanos y caribeños y
carolina abrimos entonces la puerta para
dos preguntas que tengo para hacerle la
primera vamos a empezar con la primera
como podría entonces alcanzar nuestra
región la autosuficiencia para evitar
esta crisis alimentaria estamos muy
lejos de alcanzar la digamos sobre todo
en la materia de mitigar esas
desigualdades y hacer una distribución
más equitativa posible de los alimentos
teniendo en cuenta que nosotros
producimos para alimentar para para ser
autosuficientes pero como hacer entonces
para para que esos alimentos lleguen a
las personas
efectivamente como tú dices el problema
de américa latina no es un problema de
la cantidad total de alimentos que se
produce sino de dónde se producen cómo
se distribuyen entre los países y
subregiones y sobre todo como distintos
grupos de los ciudadanos de américa
latina y del caribe pueden acceder o no
a esos alimentos
desgraciadamente en américa latina y el
caribe la reducción de pobreza se quedó
estancada
desde
2014 para las zonas rurales 2016 para
zonas urbanas o se redujo muy lentamente
y eso con la pandemia ha generado un
problema de acceso de capacidad de los
pobladores a una canasta básica
alimentaria mínima a eso se une que en
este último periodo lo que estamos
viendo es una alta inflación de los
alimentos entonces tenemos familias que
tienen menos dinero disponible para ir a
los mercados a comprar alimentos y
tenemos a la vez alimentos cada vez más
caros por lo tanto la capacidad real de
las familias para agenciarse alimentos
suficientes ha disminuido de manera
importante afectando por supuesto a la
porción más vulnerable de la
distribución pues el problema aquí
central hoy día es asegurar que todos
los latinoamericanos y caribeños tengan
acceso físico es decir que hayan
alimentos disponibles y acceso económico
es que puedan consumir una canasta
alimentaria básica
hoy con una segunda pregunta que tenía
pendiente los fertilizantes un 300 por
ciento más claro cómo reducir esta
dependencia de los fertilizantes que
venían mayoritariamente de rus y también
le quiero preguntar no sé si si tienes
la respuesta de cómo hacer para
producirlos aquí para mitigar ese esa
escasez de fertilizantes que
posiblemente se pueda alargar porque la
guerra continúa
efectivamente es como región la mayor
parte de los países de américa latina el
caribe son dependientes de importaciones
de fertilizantes de otros lugares siendo
rusia uno de los principales
exportadores
hoy día hay dos problemas uno
restricción mes al comercio de
fertilizantes por problemas de movilidad
de congestión la federación rusa ha
ampliado la cuota de exportación de
fertilizantes o sea que esto debería
ayudar a aliviar el problema
pero también hay un problema como tú
señalas de precios y esto no se debe
sólo a la guerra sino al incremento
sostenido en los precios de los
combustibles insumo principal para la
creación de los fertilizantes y por ello
tenemos al igual que en el caso de los
alimentos poco abastecimiento y un
cambio en la oferta global de
fertilizantes pero además un alto costo
de esos fertilizantes cuando se
consiguen todos tenemos dos problemas de
oferta de stock físico y de altísimos
precios nuevamente
los productores de menores recursos que
son productores de alimentos para la
región enfrentan un problema serio
porque si bien han subido los precios de
sus productos han subido muchos más sus
costos no sus posibilidades de producir
se ven afectadas